sono dietro cela dietro l'orecchio
dietro
cento
ecco dio
semmai basta basta
va preso al preso lucia
bene tutti ragazzi e benvenuti che sono
video sono fa vj oggi siamo con il buon
stefano ciao raga abbiamo deciso di fare
mine che l'ha visto che l'altra volta
abbiamo vinto che siamo forti perché
abbiamo fatto le creazioni bellissime
abbiamo deciso di fare un'altra sfida
che si chiama bad wars giusto adwords
iena tipo una skywards solo che se muori
puoi rispondere è l'obiettivo è quello
di distruggere il letto degli altri
perché quello eletto che ti permette di
esplorare siamo io e te e contro altri
14 stronzi facciamo un culo così 10 avrà
aspetta che gli stati dieci secondi è
certo ok quindi sono io e te contro
altri quattordici pezzi di merda
però noi lasceremo sulla nostra isola è
ora devo spiegati un po come funzionari
mi devo mettere letto allora vedi qua
dietro questo c'è uno che mi guarda
mentre dormi un pervertito
e allora qui nasceranno dei materiali ok
lei con questi materiali noi andiamo qui
a sinistra e ci compriamo determinati
blocchi va bene prendi materiali e
provvedere un attimo gli scambi per
capire come funzionano ok con i blocchi
dobbiamo creare subito dei ponti e
andare a prendere gli altri materiali
ok mi sto prendendo così diamanti che
sono fondamentali e aiuto
sarajevo arrivo arrivo stefano allievo
canon copiando il letto loro la tuba in
base e prendi i materiali che ci sono e
ricopre il letto si capo bisogna fare un
sacco di teamwork questo gioco è basato
sul team quindi devo coprire il letto
tantissimo
tanta roba ok capi possibilmente con i
materiali più duri possibili c'è un
materiale molto duro i duri più duri
sono arrivati sono arrivati sono
arrivati è capito la vita di soletta non
state davvero prima mi disse no c'è uno
stronzetto sopra che si sta in curando i
diamanti vado io vado io lavoro per il
cazzo c'è una spada si va dai perfetto e
sto arriva verso di me io lo ammazzo ti
ammazzo
stai attento loro e se muori perdi tutto
l'inventario tetto si odia meno male sia
morti entrambi sono c'è proprio spaccato
il letto è un miracolo pamela ammazzato
ci ammazzate vicenda va bene abbiamo un
po perso tutti i materiali e basta non è
un problema tranquillo
noi non siamo messi molto bene perché
loro hanno il controllo del diamante sto
arrivando
sta arrivando anch'io non si farà ma
questo alimento 15 pt però avanti
estremamente torna anche io ti sarò a
vita
un sacco di soldi strapazzo che cade
ammazzano o chiocchio arrivato a occhio
ci fu ucciso lato bravo letto letto per
marzo la massima marzo al massimo ok
arrivo genitori consiglio fare consiglio
arrivando anch'io ma non hanno più spada
di rendere liberi di legge l'ammazziamo
staccato dai primi lavori bravo
bravissimo ore no non l'ho ammazzata si
sta bene vai sul letto e sul letto
romanzo io per me ho ucciso mia madre si
no
ma non bisogna fermarsi ora devo andare
devo andare ora è tranquillo non sarà
bellissima non rompiamo sullo stato di
rompiamo ce l'avevamo quasi fatta per un
pelo perché se prendi diamanti aumenti
la produzione nella nostra base così
prendiamo il doppio dei materiali
arrivando sta arrivando che venga pure
attaccare 696 caduto su scusa o
chiocchio occhio stato ucciso vai a tra
l'altro le due mappe la réunion e quegli
altri due io li tengo io tengo gli altri
due nomi non sono solo le marche la cisl
ha detto spacca e le tutele to hell
spagnolo tullio io mi tengo gli altri
spaccato che vengo 88 rotte rotolavo
nola staccare il nostro basta che il
nostro basta che il nostro pezzo di
merda baseball gisa l'ha uccisa forte
aiuto di stato
ha ucciso il tempo a testa pensare che
arriva qualcuno ha intenzione arriva con
attenzione con michele ucciso in tempo
non so come ho fatto
bravo te lo giuro era davanti al letto
stabile spacca grande si picchiano
ancora le mani con le mani nude mani
merda no sul midex a porta che tutto è
allora la parola ucciso dopo no ci
saranno uccisa non si è preoccupato non
si sa non puoi capire sull'asia
tranquillo adesso respira la base di
quelli che abbiamo ucciso e operativa
quindi noi possa accogliere i loro
materiali grande meno male
arrivando una storia ne fossero mi ha
visto e ha visto secondo te non mi ha
visto ammazza l'ho ucciso ha ucciso mai
mai direction in base alla loro sono in
base al valore se fosse come se come sta
arrivando
non ci sono ci sono stefano bestia il
letto spaccano il lettone tempi dove
tempo occupati loro ma come locale o
crociere no no mi affondato nel vuoto
favi ammazza li ammazza ii entrambi sti
stronzi grande ampio spacco legno
o come lo spacca un legno schifoso non
si rompeva il legno non si rompeva nora
che non si non piova legno e che con lo
spacco in legno con le mani mani nude si
adagia prendevo sta arrivando a stare a
notte ha senso un pacco la faccia ci
sono anch'io problema sta arrivando di
autorizzazione su marco lo ammazzerei
bravo bravo bravo giu butta giu e morto
è morto dai 16 creato lang lang ha
tuttora google equa spetta orca dei casi
tirato lo conosciamo bene
si va là ho visto un bianco visto un
bianco brand sta salendo in cima può
costruire più di lì è morto ed
efficiente se si ci dato così eccoci no
hanno distrutto nel nostro letto mi sa
solo dietro cela dietro la reazione o
dietro
hai una valigia in suo aiuto ecco di
ormai basta basta
ma pregio preso lucia
mica legolas non mi hai salvato il culo
quella cecchinato male non si è fatto il
miracolo non so chi tu abbia fatto o
incredibile e storica ste cose storia
come non li vedo qua non ci sono non ci
sono lander aa aspetta che c'è di nuovo
un viola che rompe il cazzo che mezzo la
nostra parte e caduto l'hai preso è
accaduto non lo so ma non si possa
credere la venere
ciao
aiuto ma vi è il pane e il 26 26
ecco mi vieni qua ma il torneo ma se con
un bastone marco remaschi perché noi
abbiamo allora siamo in due contro due
alla fine siamo siamo in finale
il problema è che loro hanno letto e noi
no quindi ognuno ma il bianco la inciso
sì l'ha ucciso ci sono tante
bravo ha preso come morto uno grave ma e
spadaro spadaro story maggio è stato
solo dei golem ha evocato i gol questo è
scemo non morire spiega ti prego vai a
te ti ha ucciso
se ti reggi sul gioco io ma che vai
pinci per me devo tornare in una base
per forza perché non un materiale che
animerà le notti occhi occhi occhio
scappa scappa corri uccisa dagli amici a
sei un killer rambo vado ad ammazzarmi
ma hanno rotto il cazzo non ho preso i
materiali non ho preso io vado vado a
non ha preso le chiavi della macchina
vaio possono prendere i pezzi per fare
il ponte non li ho presi coprendo quasi
vai vai bravissimo ce l'hai come lo
struzzo note
non credo infatti
come hai fatto salvarti c'è pure hendel
per il peso così caduto è stata la
partita della madonna è stato bellino la
partita fantastica cioè la cecchina
tacche da tutti era la leggendaria dai
va bene va bene e fotte sega va bene va
bene ragazzi è stata una partita
bellissima
stefano è molto tranquillo e stato
infatti un guaio che se c'è si è rotta
la sedia di ghiaccio stefy per aver
fatto i quali abbiamo spaccato tutti in
casa ho trovato il suo canale in
descrizione cosa in sé ragazzi vi è
piaciuto certamente mi piace anche i
social comunista una descrizione dei
servizi siete riusciti vediamo il
prossimo video bene ragazzi dai ragazzi
[Musica]